ah yeah little notes all the slides are
up on Twitter so I'm you can find them
here and follow along if you like on my
my Twitter Ravine Carla sorry
Canyon 289 right here so optional but if
you want to follow along you can and
this is a super non-technical talk
talking about how to engage your
business with data very much along the
lines at the keynote this morning it's
not plying that but listening to it same
idea so let's go through the tech all
right so academic and work background
this will be relevant in a second so
I've worked at a bunch of companies over
time I'm a lot of small companies one
super old fortune 500 type of company
like 50,000 employees in a gazillion
dollars in revenue one particular famous
private company that you can find on
LinkedIn and I now work for sweet green
which is a restaurant startup I've also
I'll point out that I interviewed a
bunch of companies and any Reiser
interesting because you learn a lot
about a role when you're interviewing
that's so it's a two-way conversation
but my degrees are in a technical
background and so a lot of these things
I learned the hard way
I've changed my chains a lot over the
last let me call it ten years I guess
we're gonna be stuck with this black bar
so we will live with it looks like it
thinks it's not dual-mode all right well
it's gonna be black bar so a note on
open source I'll do a little
bait-and-switch here because this is PI
data so open source is awesome and
important and it's the kind of the point
of this conference so I if you haven't
considered contributing open source in
any way monetarily working for open
source pitching things writing tutorials
please do so and if you don't know how
you can talk to anybody in a green shirt
a lot of us are here contribute to open
source so please do so so I'm gonna also
contributed to PI mc3 and and RV's these
buttons help alright so soft skills talk
I'm a bunch of these numbers will be
estimate so including that one I
actually don't know how many numbers I
guesstimate it or well guesstimate
throughout the course of this talk if
something is a real number it'll be
it'll have like
footnote and they'll be a link that's
hidden right behind here so let's talk
about the set up for this talk and you
have new graduates Steve he just got a
math degree he Bachelor super excited to
join the workforce and he got a job at
this place called mushroom marketplace
it's a two sided market place where
mushroom foragers can sell their
mushrooms to mushroom aficionados so
pretty standard two-sided marketplace
job now that a lot of kind of business
model a lot of companies follow so first
question obviously is this a place to
get drugs no obviously not this is a
place for legitimate people to do
legitimate business and this is part of
the problem for mushroom marketplace
people keep you know abusing the
platform and posting listings for
mushrooms that are poisonous
they'll kill users typically not
something you want customer acquisition
costs are really high if you've ever
worked in the trend model or they'll get
people high which some people might want
but you probably don't want it as a
business because it's pretty illegal
it's hard to run an illegal business on
the Internet
so his job is the entry-level mushroom
quality analysis so what he does he gets
paid somewhere between sixty to eighty
thousand dollars you know typical it's
on an entry level job you know it gets
benefits so his parents are happy and
what he has to do is verify each
listening whether it violates the Terms
of Service of this of this platform
pretty mind-numbing job also a very
common job a lot of even the big
high-tech companies that do a lot of
machine learning stuff they have a lot
of these jobs where people need to sift
through listings and it can turn out to
be pretty tedious all right here's the
marketplace you get you get like a
picture so this is one data point you
get a picture of a of a listing and then
you get some like classification level
category like numerical activates about
this mushroom so Steve being pretty
ported this job stumbles upon this
really cool website and he sees all
these listings for this cool data
science stuff that all these people are
doing super excited because you know
this is what's on the news all the time
it's amazing he also learns I get peas
people get paid like 200k and treated
like celebrities in some circles so he's
like okay I'm gonna I'm gonna do this
this is this is my path out of being
just sort of the transactional level
employee like this is how I can elevate
myself and
and make a bunch more money and be more
respected and sort of move on up in the
world fun game one of these is not made
up so hacker news if anyone's familiar
with it there's all there's entire blog
post about how can use in sort of the
Bazaar mentality but sort of this is
what happens in data science you see a
lot of cool new algorithms and it's very
splashy and you get a lot of headlines
and people get very excited about it so
there's sort of a strong draw especially
for you new comer to all these these
cool things that are going on so Steve
besides like a lot of people that are
sort of fresh to the job that he's gonna
hack nights and weekends to build this
mushroom classifier he's seen a lot of
how to build your first classified
tutorials he just thought Michelle
Brenner's talking how did deploy her for
service applications I can totally do
this this is a well within my reach and
it's gonna earn me like glory at work so
first she tries building you know a
neural network cuz that's obviously the
coolest algorithm that everyone has to
use for the first time every other
algorithm was trashed these days just
neural networks are bust but turns out
the really expensive different neural
networks you gotta have a lot of money
either you gotta have a GPU or pay for a
GPU instance he's just he just started
his job you know he's told to put his
money in a 401k so he doesn't have a lot
of spare funds so he decides alright
I'll just use scikit-learn and I'll
build a standard classifier instead so
yeah he learns Python he spent he learns
Jupiter notebooks he learns the basics
of random forests and he built his
machine learning model it's awesome
right he spends forever he goes through
all the pain of cleaning the data I mean
man this data is awful it doesn't have
labels at the top what the hell does all
this stuff mean but okay let me hard
code it spend all the time doing that
then I'm gonna go in and I'm gonna look
at what this is I'm gonna make a bunch
of exploratory plots a whole lot of them
and then I'm gonna fire from model and
oh my god I got 85% accuracy so what he
does he takes his new opening and goes
straight into a meeting with his boss
look at all this cool stuff I just did I
did all this data cleaning I got all
these plots aren't they cool like all
these bar charts and I built this I
built this classifier and it's got like
85% accuracy this is great
we can totally automate you know how for
this QA job things or things are gonna
be awesome and a lot of people do this
right this is a natural first step you
need to you need to do these steps to
get into doing this all
DNA analysis and you're really excited
about this right this is your first
pitch this is sort of the way you're
gonna get out this was really hard this
took you 20 hours of learning you
watched some of the YouTube videos you
watch all these tutorials you went
through all the bugs that I didn't show
you here I great he's thrilled but
things always seem to take a downturn
from here Steve's boss is really excited
Steve's boss shows excitement during the
meeting and in his glad Steve's taking
initiative and seems to be really
engaged in the job but after that it
doesn't really go anywhere right Steve
just gets back to his normal day job
nobody really asks about his model you
know he messes around with it here and
there but it doesn't get pitched to the
CEO it doesn't really go any further
than that initial meeting and I've seen
all three of these things happens Steve
continues working on this model without
it going anywhere until his orc change
maybe he gets a different boss and that
boss really doesn't like data scientist
he just gives up because he's tired of
it or he just gets frustrated at this
company and quits and finds finds a new
job um I've seen this happen numerous
numerous times sometimes it's happened
to me and that's I if you follow data
science stuff this is typically how it
goes you get very focused in the
analysis part you get that going and you
have this notebook it has results but
suddenly you get stuck so let's go into
what what went wrong or what could have
gone wrong also I'm totally open to
questions any time so if anyone wants to
interject with one please feel free but
this is where data science becomes too
narrow a lot of like data science folks
or people jumping into data you can
really focus on the data part of it
they're really focused in the machine
well the machine learning model usually
comes first because that's like the cool
flashy thing that gets you a lot of like
kudos points on how can you use or any
of the air Twitter all these other
things cuz you can't avoid the data
cleaning part so inevitably you get
bogged down to the data clinging you'll
think the machine learning will take you
most of your time the data cleaning will
take 80% of time but you struggle
through it because you know you're real
committed and then you make a lot of
visualizations which is could be good
but you make a lot of just a lot of
visualizations that tell you
tell you a lot of things and it comes
from a place of what can I do with data
science so the questions you start with
is algorithms are cool I have data how
can I use algorithms to do stuff with
data but this is pretty in congruent
with how businesses think I'm especially
looking the keynote this morning
does this is care about how can you make
money how can we keep making money right
you for making money you want to keep
making money how can you make more money
because this is usually want to make
more money not less money and the most
generic version of this is how can we
generate value and so let's talk through
this so Steve's got this cool prototype
but he's not prepared for all these
other questions that come up one set of
questions cuz I could come up this boss
could not know what any of this stuff
means at all there I mean in this room
we're fairly knowledgeable data but
there's a large subset of the population
or actually the majority the population
that doesn't know how these
visualizations are code or anything
works so it's totally lost in them how
maybe how hard this is what the value
could be and any of it they just don't
they don't get it then let's say C's
boss does understand the results right
at least understands what machine
learning algorithms are the C's boss is
the QA boss then there's a whole bunch
of other problems how do you how do you
know it's 85% right like is it gonna be
85% every time I mean how much money do
I gotta put in to put this up on this on
the server Michelle talked about
expensive server lists costs are like
you know it's not free you know who's
gonna host this and we gonna pick are
we're on GCP and you use AWS so keep
definitely a killer right there there's
more people resourcing right well your
QA analysts and if you're gonna do this
who's gonna do your job who's gonna do
the work for modifying other parts of
the application you've got internal
politics maybe Steve's boss doesn't want
this because if you automate all the
queue analysts that boss no longer has a
job which is a real thing that could
happen right you your data science is
not really zero-sum you're you're just
you could be displacing somebody you
should consider that and how that might
be received and then there's there's
legal implications like let's say
somebody gets point like this guy she's
algorithm somebody gets poisoned is the
company culpable for a machine learning
algorithm that's a black box what will
happen when there's QA analysts you sort
of have like and Facebook's as a sloshy
probably shouldn't call it a company by
name but some companies do this a lot
they say they have teams that are
people that review things and that gives
them sort of an out sometimes when their
algorithms do the wrong thing and that
is a very interesting strategy that
seems to be working really well right
now and the same question comes up for a
mushroom marketplace if we replace
everyone with an algorithm and somebody
gets hurt
who's to blame for the algorithm its
decision super-important with things
like self-driving cars and all net CCPA
GDP are so we don't have a cc pay talk
but for those unaware there's a there's
a Europe past this pretty landmark
ruling on customer data protection and
then California is putting one in on
January 1st that is sort of freaking
everyone out including us because you
have to be very set you have to be very
careful with people's data so are there
any concerns there I mean I could just
keep going on because these are all the
things I could think that change is hard
maybe the business works great right now
they don't need to put a machine
learning algorithm in it's just seem
something it's like something new that
that's not doesn't help them make money
it doesn't doesn't matter the maybe the
algorithm is great but it's just super
expensive to run that's a cost and then
the last one being customer value it's
like does anyone actually care about the
result outputs I I've seen a lot of
machine learning models been built where
nobody actually really cares what the
model says and makes it really hard to
put it into business if nobody actually
gets any value from it and so the
general point here is that the analysis
is like the very first part right and if
you there's a lot of things that can
sink your prototype and you have to
consider a lot easy and I don't even
listed all of them here so let's talk
about someone else oh sorry just switch
here so before starting a data science
project the algorithms and the data are
important of course because that's the
central core of any data analysis
project it's the name but you should
also consider who will look customer B
right like why would why would somebody
want these results why would they matter
are they multiple customers and they're
not it also considered what the cost
will be and you certainly have there's
multiple costs here you have you have
your time costs that's probably the one
you're the most sensitive to but how
much money will it cost to deploy how
many people will it take you have to
hire consultants consider what it will
take to get this thing not just to the
prototype but all the way to the value
creation stage consider where the
businesses
is the business looking to grow is it a
company that is sort of quote unquote
data thinking and they want to do this
that's that's a very relevant are yeah
are other companies in your space paying
a lot for data science and then
internally are you in a politically
strong Department does your manager have
a lot of political sway if fortunately
or unfortunately if you work with
somebody or work under somebody that
doesn't have a lot of political sway
your prototypes might not make it far
because they don't have the resources or
the ability to to get it in front of the
CEO at smaller companies it'll be a
little easier for me you can approach
somebody but like at large companies I'm
never gonna see the CEO of the company I
worked for ever I'm not I don't have
enough sway and even my boss three
levels up doesn't have enough sway to
see this multinational CEO and what not
so consider the context of the
organization that you work in and
whether you're going to be able to
influence the change you need to support
what you're doing and a big one to you
is that I think sometimes people forget
is what's the risk of these analyses
there's there's sort of two levels of
these so obviously the the one people
think about is what if my analysis is
wrong in some of the companies I worked
at if an analysis was wrong people could
die that's a pretty big deal this in
this case I it's a big deal here I'll be
honest that sweet green people won't die
if their salads are late so it's a
little bit easier than the last one I
worked at so I can be a little bit more
I can accept a lower bar a model a cushy
in some cases because a late salad it's
not as bad as somebody I yeah somebody's
Tony's death so what could happen but
then there's also the sort of subtle
ones is like how hard is it to keep the
results right so prototypes are cool but
I are the results gonna be right three
months from now after a bunch of stuff
has changed like this there's right now
and then there's right over time as you
create value that's that can be a
challenge there's another one that's
also subtle one is what if the analysis
is a is right but people think it's
wrong so people will you'll be right and
you're all going to be right but it's so
contrary to people's expectations
they'll react negatively to it then the
converse is what if your analysis is
wrong when people think it's right
so sometimes
people will see wrong analysis but the
lovely results so much they'll start
spreading it and then you have another
problem on your hands so consider all
these things of the risk of publishing
analysis and what will happen and then
oh the biggest question is uh you should
really like deep dive think are you
doing this because you saw cool post and
I can use and you really want to
implement neural nets because that's
like the cool LCM thing that you just
saw or do you really feel like it'll
truly affect the customer I would say a
lot of the time especially these
engineers or people that are in data
than Instagram we are really excited
about the algorithms and then we sort of
fool ourselves that it'll be actually
valuable in a business and then when we
actually pitch it to a business person
and they they have drawing realities
it's not very available it's it's
painful and hurtful but try and avoid
that by asking really digging in and
it's figuring out if this actually has
value beforehand so we're going through
another case study I'm gonna talk about
Avery and truffle traders so we've a ver
e is also a new graduate similar to
Steve has a math degree at another
well-known university
she works at a company called truffle
traders which has a surprisingly similar
business model to mushroom marketplace
she's also frustrated though she doesn't
want to just be a sort of a
transactional a transactional
replaceable employee she wants to be
sure she's you can move up so she's the
same idea let me create a machine
learning model that will automate this
quality analysis job so instead of me
classifying whether out mushrooms are
are I guess in this case truffles are
poisonous or or of the psychedelic type
and not of the edible regular edible
type let me create an algorithm to do it
but she thinks about that she thinks
about these things first what's the
current what's the current challenge the
companies having what are they looking
are the challenge growth as a challenge
is the challenge bad QA is this
challenge resourcing and then what's
being told in the all-hands so quick
hack of companies at All Hands meetings
you usually get tidbits of information
about what the CEO cares about those are
good meetings to like listen in and
figure out what the higher-ups are
thinking about she also thinks through
what departments were going to need to
be involved if she creates a model what
are the resources she thinks about if I
create an m/l model how can I create
step value step wise not just
a full-blown model like are there sort
of sub goals I can hit that'll get me
there and then what are some concrete
plans for action to remember if you go
back to Steve no action plan there just
an algorithm Avery thinks about what it
what would people might do um I'm gonna
note that these are yes some of the
relevant questions but this is not an
exhaustive list of relevant business
questions so what a 'very does is rather
than jumping shape to the algorithm she
thinks about the whole business process
not just the data portion so the
workflow here is that somebody publishes
something to mushroom marketplace so I
is a user I'll found some mushrooms
somewhere in LA might be dangerous
and I put them on the site for someone
to buy because we don't know whether the
mushrooms are good or not for sale they
go through QA process it takes about a
day because somebody has to manually
verify it and users are annoyed right
that slows down their business velocity
you have to come back the next day to
see whether their mushroom listing was
accepted no it's a real pain for free
users she realizes that you know what
machine learning algorithms they have a
distinct advantage here they can provide
instant results right so this is a
better user experience you get told
instantly whether your listing is is not
over time this is great she's thought
about a way that it actually affects
users not that it's just a koala rhythm
um she's heard that mushroom marketplace
is a bit competitive the CEO doesn't
like and so she also knows that you know
this whole idea of a total domination of
an industry is like the cool thing to do
even if you're losing a bunch of money
to get there so her ceo's totally
aligned with that vision of pushing as
fast as possible and she knows the
engineering team doesn't have time to
help her out because they've got a huge
backlog doing the normal stuff and she
knows that for her sub motive her
selfish motive of getting a raise her QA
director is the one who's gonna be who's
gonna be giving the raises out right so
if she gives if you give something to
the customer experience director that
might not help or get raises as much as
she she helps out her own her own boss
so she wants to figure out how could she
leverage data science to learn at work
get a raise and have a greener future of
strategic work which is transactional
work just what a lot of people strive
for in their careers so she comes up
with a plan so instead of developing the
real-time classifier that would be
required for a for a customer she won't
get the engineering resources to put
that thing up
see that there's a she figures out a sub
playing though you can make a batch
model which means that she'll just
generate predictions at the end of the
day and what you'll do is she'll just
use it to double-check the work of her
own quality analyst so rather than put
this out with customers she'll just
she's already QA she's in the department
she's got all their friends and
colleagues around here they're already
doing the work she can just run the
model after they've done their manual
classification to see what the model
would say so the things that come in
here no engineering work a very little
engineering work because it's a batch
model right much simpler to run that a
full spark streaming type of model no
additional risk because no business
processes are being modified the regular
work still happening so you're good
there we checked off that box her boss
will be happy with it so it's a
politically savvy move and she'll get
she'll get free help on training
examples so this is a big one if
anyone's actually tried building a
machine learning classifier and like
labeling day yourself I don't know if
anyone wants to label ten thousand data
points themselves but it usually is a
huge pain and that's like the minimum
bar you need so now she can leverage
your whole department and get there get
their help for free because they're
already doing the classification work
and if they just need to validate the
model on top with all the work they're
doing and it builds confidence in a safe
setting so her team maybe hasn't used
machine learning before they might be
dubious or suspicious this gives her a
way to introduce it in a non jarring
fashion so she's checked off a lot of
boxes here and what she does is instead
of putting together in a notebook she
puts together this deck she gets a
PowerPoint deck together and she goes
through it so she sets up a very similar
meeting with a boss she uses a title
using data to protect customers in the
subtitle automated mushroom Quality
Assurance double checks her challenge
lays it out we have to process a large
volume of mushroom listings we can make
mistakes the cost of a wrong mushroom
listing might be three thousand dollars
so plus the the unquantifiable risk to
brain damage if we if one goes through
all right so cool we have our cattle
side we have the current challenge she
talks about what machine learning is so
leveraging data and she also throws in
this jab that mushroom marketplace might
also be using this technology so let me
jump into the role of Avery here so if I
talk about the currency
model I've done the initial data
exploration a common you know method
called decision trees is used it's
pretty easy method where you sort of
you're out a fork and you're like does
the mushroom have this color if it's
brown then it's probably poisonous if
it's white then it's maybe not poisonous
that's how the decision trees work right
now my algorithm gets about 3 out of 20
right and then if you want actually
details I have all the mathematical
analysis in the backend and this is an
example of one chart of how many sort of
cap shapes we get for all these
mushrooms here's my proposal I the QA
analysts don't have to do anything
different with their work they just
continue looking through listings as
normal what I'll do is I'll generate a
spreadsheet at the end of the day I'll
look at all the listings that we covered
today from all 10 people than artists
team I'll run my model over them and
then I just want the queue analyst to
double-check the ones that are
misclassified there won't be too many
because I have a pretty high accuracy
rating and it's good to do so because
now we're just double-checking that a
customers are safe timewise I don't
think it'll be too much 15 minutes from
each of the analysts and I'm willing to
put in 30 minutes extra each day um
I think you know we can reduce the
number of misses from 10 percent to 8
percent and that'll save us about 60 ke
with all the recalls and packaging and
things that we need to do and I the
model will get better over time this is
just something that comes up with
machine learning so we're starting to 85
but as I improve on it maybe we'll get
to 1995 or higher there's no additional
risk because we're not doing much
different and I just need two weeks to
train the analyst and we'll be we'll be
good to go on this and so future steps
you know there's a couple things that
I'm considering you know I have this
thing called an accuracy metric and I
might change it to you to recall metric
I just think sometimes it's maybe we
want to go through a little bit more of
the listings and just to make sure that
we don't have any that go up poorly and
this this metric which will help with
that
if this works out well we can work with
the engineering team to to get more
resources and sort of help out with the
flow and then if this is if this works
out great maybe we can start
collaborating and put this into the
customer workflow and so that's sort of
the pitch we'll give and let me talk
about why this is different actually
much different than the notebook so
notebook sorry I'm just gonna say -
touristy business unfriendly so if
you're pitching to somebody that is not
a notebook user actually even if you are
pitching
book user there's a lot of ways to make
a bad notebook so just because you make
a notebook doesn't put you in the
success realm already there are ways to
make good notebooks for other people to
read and that's a whole nother talk but
nope Jupiter notebooks themselves are
not things that are easily presentable
in front of executives and I'll just say
that blatantly is part of my own
experience they're hard for people to
open they don't they don't look well
good in emails Google slide turns out
especially the GC turns out to be great
so quick hack here the first slide
always shows up on the email body on a G
suite so like when you want to get
people's limited attention this slide
will show up you want to make sure that
it's kept its eye-catching it very
clearly explains what's going on and and
it doesn't require a math degree to
figure out what it means so the first
slide is is important for advertising
reasons for that and so I think Avery
did a good job here I know give myself
self credit I did a great job here by by
putting in just the standard title and
subtitle laying out the challenges a
good one too so the other thing with
your analyses is you're not going to be
able to present them to everybody but
will typically happens you'll present
them to one or two people and then your
hope is that it'll grow legs and it'll
get forwarded on to other people alright
so you're not always gonna be pitching
your work you should make sure that
you're laying out all the things you
went through so the two things that are
that work out here is you're laying out
the challenge that the business has
hopefully this is visible and everybody
understands it no data or anything is
being used here other than you want to
lay out what the the business hurt is
here so in this case they're losing
money but it could be any any number of
things for whatever the business happens
to be
I'd say it's usually good to put in a
slide about an entry-level slide about
machine learning for good in it for
better and for worse machine learning
and AI and all these things are way in
the hype train they're on CNN so a lot
of different people could have a lot of
opinions about what machine learning is
better without you know being in the
details so a slide that explains the
high-level approach helps people that
are seeing this deck and not familiar
with ml in general and then the painful
part is not showing like 95% of your
analysis the real trick here is pulling
out the one or two bits that are really
important better
somebody can read not showing every
single visualization used to debug your
entire classifier and all the
exploratory stuff and putting the
putting the metrics in a way that's easy
for people understand so another
challenge is machine learning there are
a lot of different types of metrics
they're not very well understood by a
lot of people so trying trying to word
the metrics in a way that comes up in
the in a business-friendly language and
not the scikit-learn I pulled the
straight out of the documentation
language a proposal for action so what
do we do after this when am I gonna
require what am I gonna need important
for two reasons
it tells every sauce what she plans to
do it also helps Avery's boss know what
could that boss whether it's he or she
what could that boss do for Avery so
Avery might need engineering support
Avery's boss can start working on those
things
Avery Avery will need two weeks of time
from the team Avery's boss can allow for
this this plan for action makes it
really connection holder in the meeting
to actually go do these things and then
this sort of optional but future steps
of it like what the cool stuff in there
features to be so everything that's
totally giving up provision for the
customer the customer real-time model
but just showing it as a feature set
that's not required in the first phase
step this sort of analysis is much more
business friendly and in my opinion then
running into a meeting and showing off a
Jupiter notebook this you lose people
incredibly fast in my prior experience
just to get a pull from the audience
does anyone had a great presentation
with the Jupiter notebook like run in
it's gone off great sorta well how did
that one go yeah it depends because some
people are comfortable with code and
have a good visual insight and can tell
some of these things reporting but a lot
of executives are either really busy
they don't have the time to sort of
separate the wheat from the chaff so
that's one challenge or a lot of them
just gonna I'm gonna point out there's a
lot of non-technical departments that's
not a bad thing they serve important
functions like legal and people resource
and things like that but there it'll be
challenging for them to grasp onto your
key insights alright
so why is this better than see some of
the things we talked about I think
business plus data is greater than just
data so Avery considers the business
context she knows where her proposal
should should fit in that business
context this is incredibly important
consider what you are in the business
and what the business needs she comes up
with a plan rather than a prototype if
you start with the prototype there's two
reasons this will be challenging you
won't really know where you're going so
that'll make it hard for you to actually
finish you'll just keep packing on and
you'll feel like you need to do this
thing forever and then you won't
actually know how to get past the
prototype so everyone that starts with
the prototype first I've seen then it
has to somehow merge this prototype into
some hacky version of something that'll
actually work if it gets deployed its
knotted to think about where it's got to
be because then your actual engineering
will be better not then not just your
analysis concise communication so being
able to express concepts really quickly
is actually a really big business skill
is something that I'm still challenged
with and still trying to learn but you
in business settings you sometimes only
have seconds to make a point and gain it
turns a foothold in a conversation and
trying to explain what a confusion
matrix is is not gonna happen in that
span of time so you better come up with
quick ways of explaining what's
happening and then coming up with a
strategy
so there's hurdles for implementing
anything recognizing those hurdles
before you come up with a prototype and
so some of you might be saying like I
already date a scientist like I don't
have to do any this crap I just make
notebooks all day and the fact is it's
it's because you're probably working for
someone that already did all the stuff
for you right your CEO or your your
manager they're justifying your pay
they're justifying the legal expenses
they've done this work and they've
created this small space where you can
just be a data scientist which is cool
if you just want to be data scientist
your whole life but I think a lot of you
will realize that you don't to spend a
forty you want to then move up from
there and so if you want to move to the
managerial role you're gonna have to
learn all of these skills anyway because
that's what managers have to do they
have to create space for their employees
and these skills are required to do so
so I'm gonna give you the high-level
practical guidance and so consider the
context surrounding the data don't just
consider the data in the algorithm
think about the business and the people
overall box in my experience this has
been half or more of the time has been
just working with the people to either
communicate what I've done or working
through roadblocks that have come up for
budgeting reasons
political reasons or change reasons like
any any one of these things that Hoffman
um you're gonna have to learn to be
patient it's a lot faster to a computer
listen to me a lot better than people
listen to me
computers just do what I tell them to do
and then tell me when I screw up but
they do it instantly people take a while
to change and then think about other
people's perspectives I think when we
get wrapped up the analysis we don't
always consider how other people would
view this or what they would need to do
so put yourself in other people's shoes
and then the hardest one is that not
every problem requires a data solution
like a lot of problems actually don't
require you to do solutions and a lot of
problems that actually work fine if
people just do them and it'll look
manually frustrating but like as a
business you don't need an algorithm to
solve all your your problems and that's
the painful thing you might have to come
up with your business might not need
I don't know MapReduce for their Excel
workbooks which is a thing I've heard
about people ask well you don't need to
do for everything this just goes way
past data the engineering tools don't
always fit the me so since this is I
want to give you things to Google
because this is a whole topic and of
itself but where's the research include
things like coalition building how to
work with different people and get them
onto the same page like so how do you
get to department heads to want to work
together and build your model
influencing change in people it's a good
one obviously communication and
negotiation or be and then I'm a big one
since a part of this is people wanting
the progression that career is just
personal branding right like it do
people be you as an expert in that in
that company do they use a data expert
how do they be you and that'll that all
has a lot of effect on how your analyses
will get presented and where they'll get
shown and so like data skills I
presented like when I say data right
there's a lot that goes into data
there's there's analyst analyst skills
with tableau there's data science skills
with machine learning and in algorithmic
approaches there's there's a engineering
which is a lot of like how to set up
infrastructure right just like that
there's the same sub disciplines in in a
sort of business strategy skill so think
about it that way as well
and there's no one-size-fits-all so I
think there's a no free lunch thing for
algorithms you know one algorithm
doesn't solve every possible data
science problem ever and it's the same
thing with with these skills
presentation skills are like 140
but you can also have to learn verbal
communication skills outside of
presentations you have to learn how P&L
works companies and some level finance
like there's a lot of these little
pieces that you'll pick up over time so
I'm gonna give you a bunch of resources
to go into this so from people that are
technical if we there's Vicki boy kiss
as a data scientist in Philadelphia
she's actually really good I think and
she's got this great blog where she
talks about the softer side of data
science so I have a bunch of articles
that are relevant to this talk but her
whole sub stock blog is actually very
good Scott Hanselman he is a he's a
developer not a data scientist but he
has a really good blog post that's just
the longness about how technology
doesn't always have to do the latest and
greatest to be useful in a business and
and how there's a lot of people that you
know use angular 1.4 or VBA and they do
perfectly fine in the company they don't
need to switch to Python 3 year and any
Scala and all this other stuff and a lot
of companies are posted on this too so
in companies engineering blog posts so
now I'm just read into the articles that
aren't just like how to set up Hadoop
and MapReduce or service or any of these
things they're blog post from like
Airbnb that talked about how they set up
data focused organizations and in there
you'll learn what are the managers
thinking about because these are the
rules that you're trying to get you
should realize how they're being created
for you so in this post area movie talks
a lot about whether data science teams
are great centralized whether they
should all work in one area whether they
should be split apart in different
regions and the pros and cons of each
these have very real consequences to the
efficacy of of organizations of whether
you're an embedded data scientist in the
data department or whether you're on
someone else's team like a lot can
change between those those types of
things and then completely outside of
the scope of data there's there's a
Harvard Business Review and sort of
these management consulting or NBA type
articles
I know MBAs probably a dirty word here
somebody will hopefully won't beat me up
after this but MBAs a me a tape articles
like Harvard Business Review have a lot
of great tips on how to make data useful
in an organization these are to where
they're on like on the cover article but
these days actually they have a almost
every are every every magazine has at
least one article about how data can be
useful in the organization they have all
the other ones of course
how did you restructuring and finance
things and what to take risk and not but
buried in there are really good tidbits
about how data is being used at Google
and their people on the analytics
department how it failed in the people
analytics department in certain ways and
how Google overcame that you can learn
you can use these to develop those
skills of the softer side of data
there's also plenty of just generally
good books I have three of them posted
here that have helped me and but these
are ways to to work on negotiations so a
really good example for something
negotiate on you presented analysis and
your boss which is like great can you
put it in production next week and
suddenly you're gonna find yourself in a
negotiation to get enough timeline to
actually build this thing right or
you're gonna work a lot of weekends I
get frustrated so whether you think
you're negotiating or not by just being
at a company you're always engaging in
some level of negotiation and it's good
to understand how that dynamic works and
in Coursera has a lot of great courses
on these as well so between these four
hopefully one of these will help you I'm
actually got five sorry another one
and there's also podcast so there's just
there's this podcast called career tools
and I want to make sort of the pitch
that even if even if you feel like
you're gonna move out of data or you
become a product manager like just by
engaging in a job you have to develop a
whole set of skills to flourish in that
in that position so you know if you're
putting ten out of ten chips on data
science my advice would be maybe you
know spend eight to ten on the data
science stuff do the self-driving nano
degree and watch the YouTube watch these
PI data talks or whatever but then put
two out of ten on on the soft skills and
in areas where you can improve it work
in your presentation address or whatever
it may be and so with that I'll take
questions thanks oh great oh come on
[Applause]
yeah you mentioned wanting to have
somebody in the chain for the
accountability portion of that what's
the long-term solution that you see for
that especially is the Facebook you're
mentioning wants to have those belly
buttons and that account that person for
accountability what will be the solution
I mean it's so this is where I'm I I
will give the blanket statement that
this is why my presentation was so
generic it's gonna depend heavily on
where your business is what country you
work in what country your applications
gonna get a point in right and because
suddenly all every company who's here is
gonna be accountable for the data in in
their servers for California all of them
because see CPAs coming in January first
and now a legal department is now
informing decisions that we were
previously just making out like by
ourselves and this is just because
California just changes their ruling so
the generic answer is it depends but I
think you should definitely spend the
discovery work to understand who's
accountable for cost right who's gonna
pay for this thing who's accountable for
the people that you need because you
might need engineering resources
somebody will be putting this data in
whether it's a customer whether it's
your company
somebody's accountable for those people
so you wanna you know if you're like
Mark Rhoda who's a volunteer here he's
accountable for the people that are
trying to defraud Ticketmaster and so
he's got to make sure that he knows
who's working with those people or
figuring out what to do with those
people and then there's legal and people
so think for your business all the
people that required all the legal
considerations and those are the people
that'll be accountable on your list so
in my company for example my boss
another department has given me like a
cute little mini challenge just to sort
of like see what data is about because
he's trying to be more data-driven and
you know my mind as a data scientist is
like let's do fancy models and stuff I
was wondering what your take is on
trying to leverage that opportunity and
have the executive think of it not just
as like a cute project with like a cute
like accuracy result but something that
they can actually use so you know you're
trying to get out of this so one
you're trying to get taken seriously
right like what do you want to happen
your model do you want do you want your
reputation to be like solidified as
someone who's serious about your work do
you want this model to go in production
like what is what is your objective my
job objective is to have it go into
production and something that they can
use long-term even after I'm not there
even after I leave okay so there's a
couple of routes you can take here
one is you could you can have sort of a
hardball meeting with that boss and be
like I'm not the type of person that
just does these cutesy analysis like if
we're doing this model we're doing it
for real and so you better back it to
production I'm not doing this whatsoever
right because you have an opportunity to
cost your time and you're not gonna do
this halfway stuff you you go that route
I don't know what relation you have with
this boss or you could you could work
the other way like if if this boss isn't
taking you seriously you could find
another person and the company that will
want them they don't care about the
model but they just want the positive
results and you could try telling that
person hey I'm building this model for
my other boss but it's gonna help you
this way then that other other hopefully
high-ranking executive will hold the
that manager accountable right and then
so then you'll be able to push something
in production without you having to push
it through or you could just try and
push it to production yourself if you
have enough influence in the
organization to really slam through and
get and get what you need done but you I
would I think you're thinking the right
way I would also ask why isn't your boss
interested in this model because I in my
I'm broadly speaking here because I
don't know the situation but I feel like
there could be a tension where your boss
is maybe expecting results from you and
now you're spending 4 to 5 hours or
whatever amount of time of day doing
something that another boss wants right
and so this guy if this guy or girl is
justifying your salary and holding your
head count but you're really working for
this other person like are you going to
hurt yourself on reviews are you gonna
be shortchanging yourself on what your
boss is asking you to do so consider
maybe those factors hopefully that helps
hi great talk by the way my question is
how do you when talking to a
non-technical person about these results
how do you share your results without
oversimplifying the findings in a way
that understandable and also I guess
actionable so the most universal thing
that you can always talk about is money
like 100% everyone will
want to hear about how much money
they're either gonna make or how much
money they're gonna say so if you can if
you can get a strong pitch that you're
gonna do something with money and get it
and make someone rich they'll be very
motivated to help you out that's like
the most common denominator in almost
every business now i luckily even
fortune enough to work with businesses
that are also mission driven a two of
them at this point so if you can connect
something to the mission of the company
that's sort of another leverage point to
you to show that you're working in the
direction that the company wants to work
for I'd say those are the two most
generic and biggest lovers but other
than that like there's a this sort of
five five portions of power like you'll
do stuff for your friends because of
your friends right there's this thing
called referent power because you're
close to them so if you're really good
and people really like you that's
another way to get people to take you
seriously and want to help you out so if
your boss thinks you're a great person
and wants you to advance in a company
maybe the interest then isn't for the
company but the interest is in keeping
you at the organization and moving
forward so understand the interest I'd
say and then try and align to any those
interests of the people you're trying to
influence I think this might be our last
one quick question is when would you say
is the best time to pitch an idea a lot
of times real-world experience you have
a situation where okay I have an idea I
can create fake data and potentially
come up with a solution but at the same
time I don't want to go through the
entire process and it mounts to nothing
as well so I know a lot of this is
dependent on your manager and also CEOs
etc etc but in your experience well it's
when's the best time to get your idea
off the ground this is a tough one
because it's super context dependent but
I'd say clearly the it again depends on
what your objective is so if you're
honestly if your objective is I don't
know I'll just add anything if your
objective is just to learn like you
really just want to learn something and
use the data then the best time you just
like just go out and just do it right
because all you want to do is use the
technology but just then understand that
your objective is to learn and that it
probably won't go anywhere past your
learning that's the value of it so start
whatever if you're going to learn if
it's in a business though it's going to
depend on I like if you were to startup
that you just if it's gonna require well
because if your business requires money
did did you just race the funding round
and you have extra money to
go through things if your business had a
high-powered executive that really does
not like data does not think data is
important or does not value it that
executive just get fired well it's
pretty good time to start pitching data
because now you have that roadblock
that's gone right um did you like what
else let me try to fabricate another
scenario off the top of my head another
one could be either business growth
growth objective just got announced so
the CEO just said every every
departments got to grow their business
by 10% right that's a pretty good time
because now you might have a solution to
grow the business by ten percent or the
other one is risk if your business just
went through a huge recycle something
really bad happened like so you can also
get like create a model that'll do
something that'll be on the cost of more
insight or gain analysis or whatever so
I can't give like a one-size-fits-all
answer like it really is how big is your
company where do you work how much risk
do you want to take like are you willing
to stake yourself so hard on this model
you're gonna but you're gonna get into
your boss's office and tell them that
you if you don't get this you're gonna
quit which is a viable strategy just
you're gonna have to maybe get fired or
do you are you the type of person that
wants to play it safe and don't want it
you don't rock the boat too much so I'm
sorry I can't give you a precise answer
but those are sort of the high-level
considerations again alright thanks for
being whom our further making data
relevant in business